type d'accord qui commence ici à merci
la parole est à monsieur arnaud viala
monsieur le premier ministre à l'instar
du chef de l'état qui préfèrent confier
ses pensées profondes et ses choix
stratégiques des journalistes plutôt
qu'à son propre gouvernement
nous sommes les préférer les annonces
médiatiques aux débats de cet hémicycle
et donc à l'exercice de la démocratie
dans un courrier au sujet de la
situation internationale et du
démantèlement de la jungle de calais je
vous demander de bien vouloir m'éclairer
sur votre vision des raisons qui
conduisent des milliers de malheureux à
s'échouer au mieux sur nos côtes au pire
dans les eaux meurtrière de la
méditerranée sur la réponse qu'apporte
ou n'apporte pas l'europe à l'arrivée de
ces populations sur son sol sans
qu'aucun dispositif d'accueil digne de
ce nom ne soit prévu sur les modalités
du démantèlement du centre de calais sur
votre décision unilatérale d'organiser
je cite monsieur le ministre de
l'intérieur l'accueil des migrants dans
les départements sur l'ensemble du
territoire puisque je cite toujours
il s'agit d'une exigence de solidarité
nationale et de respect de la dignité
humaine
je le dis haut et fort et n'accepterait
pas que vous donniez à penser qu'il en
est autrement en posant ces questions
nous ne sommes ni insensible au drame
humanitaire qui se déroule sous nos yeux
ni raciste ni désireux de voir cette
misère concentré ailleurs nous sommes
simplement des élus de la nation qui
exige d'être informé de ces problèmes
majeurs de notre pays
des élus et habitants de territoire
inquiète à juste titre des français
horrifié par la montée inexorable de
sentiment de rejet et de haine que
suscite l'absence de concertation total
pour laquelle vous avez opté sur ce
sujet je réitère dont mes questions
quand organiserait vous un vrai débat
dans cet hémicycle sur la question des
migrants
quand considérez-vous enfin que si
effort national il doit y avoir les
territoires de france ne peuvent pas
être les otages passif de vaud
atermoiements
merci la parole et à monsieur le premier
ministre manuel valls
monsieur le député personnes personne
n'a dit que vous étiez vous vos
collègues insensible et encore moins
raciste le sujet n'est pas là le haut
monsieur jacob
allez allez personnes on va examiner la
réponse du premier ministre
vous avez le dossier des questions qui
sont tout à fait légitimes comme
parlementaire comme élu local
de quoi s'agit-il oui il ya un drame à
nos frontières à quelques heures d'avion
ce sont les migrants soient qui viennent
la corne d'afrique d'afrique qui meurt
en méditerranée beaucoup sont sauvés il
faut le dire aussi grâce aux ong grâce à
l'union européenne grâce à la
participation de la france
et puis il ya bien sûr nous l'évoquerons
dans un instant les drames des réfugiés
liées à la guerre en irak et surtout en
syrie avec des millions de déplacés face
à cela l'europe je l'évoquais tout à
l'heure à et toi et doit apporter encore
une réponse bien plus forte que nous
savons que d'abord la résolution passe
par la diplomatie par l'action militaire
aussi nous y reviendrons il faut aider
les pays qui accueillent les réfugiés
d'abord je pense à l'italie et bien sûr
à la grèce il faut aussi organiser mieux
nos frontières extérieures celle de
l'union européenne
nous n'avons nous jamais dit que nous
allions accueillir tous les réfugiés
tous les migrants c'est un choix
différent de celui par exemple de
l'allemagne mais nous avons dit que nous
assumerions nos responsabilités dans le
cadre du plan européen de relance à lisa
sion 280 mille réfugiés européen nous
avons dit que nous prendrions notre part
trente mille sur deux ans et puis nous
assumons nos propres responsabilités sur
calais s'agit-il de 1 million et demi un
million cinq cent mille cent mille
réfugiés non il s'agit de plusieurs
milliers de réfugiés pour la plupart
sans doute 80% qui auront le droit
d'asile dans notre pays entre 5000 à
7000 personnes qui sont
sur calais comment s'organiser bernard
cazeneuve a eu l'occasion de le rappeler
hier par une relocalisation sur
l'ensemble du territoire
oui c'est quand même assez
extraordinaire que les mêmes qui nous
parle de l'autorité de l'état
quand l'état assume ses responsabilités
en matière d'accueil sont aujourd'hui
les chantres de la démocratie
participative
un peu partout dans chaque département
et je le dis calmement
monsieur goasguen même si je sais que
vous avez eu un rôle de modération
honnêtement que nous avons vu dans le
16e arrondissement concernant l'accueil
des sdf n'a pas donné la plus belle
image de ce que peut être l'accueil
vis-à-vis de ceux qui ont besoin de la
solidarité
donc oui il est comme moi allez ça sert
à rien vous me l'avez reprocher monsieur
goasguen de brandir comme ça
ce droit menaçant cela ne m'impressionne
pas nous assumons nos rues non monsieur
goise d un haut responsable local et nos
responsabilités c'est faire en sorte que
6000 albi à lui mille personnes des
hommes des femmes des familles des
enfants puissent être accueillis dans
les meilleures conditions pour savoir
s'ils ont droit ou non ensuite à l'asile
80% l'autre jour j'étais à epernay et à
epernay
j'ai vu ce qu'on pouvait faire une
petite unité des opérateurs des
associations des professionnels comme bd
bénévoles qui font tout pour que ce
droit d'asile vivent dans les meilleures
conditions et prépare la l'intégration
de ces personnes
intégration sociale apprentissage du
français respect de nos valeurs
ceux qui n'ont pas droit à l'asile
devant être reconduit à nos frontières
voilà ce que est de la france s'était
interrogé tout à l'heure sur la place de
la france en europe et dans le monde et
bien assumé avec maîtrise responsabilité
et sérieux mais assumer nos
responsabilités et nos valeurs c'est ça
la france et je pense que de ce point de
vue là les uns et les autres nous
pourrions avancer ensemble et j'étais à
epernay l'autre jour et on me rappelait
l'homme qui avait été le maire d'epernay
bernard stasi et qui donnait une belle
image de ce que pouvait être la
générosité et la droite française
merci monsieur le premier